fashion as originally conceived it was
meant not as a panel to debate the
issues but rather offer some reflections
about the whole conference may begin by
saying that several years ago there
appeared in program five volumes of the
history of Polish diplomacy and more
recently this was summarized into anvil
but even with that I do not think that
we have really a synthesis of told ish
foreign policy over the centuries and in
a sense the idea of this conference was
to made a step in this direction we are
not trying to resolve or it was not the
intention of us to try to resolve any
problems but rather to reflect on some
of the questions a few reflections which
I'd like to offer would be along the
following lines it has the listening to
the various presentations the question
comes up to man's mind has there been a
continuity or a lack of continuity of 30
foreign policy of eccentrics obviously
conditions were changing and direct
continuity
not with life difficult in a rather
extreme statement which I like to quote
because it is that provocative by gov
ronski at the time when she was purged
minister and foreign to Vienna in the
1930s Gavroche Key says it has been the
tragedy of Poland that never had a
foreign policy worthy of the name Brock
políticas a granny she will drag and
inertia Jets now it seems to me that
apart from everything else listening to
the first few remarks observations from
preservation Corps not professor Novak
we see how complex the question of
foreign policy of programmed was over
the centuries the one thing which struck
me was the fragmentation of the
decision-making power and the
multiplicity of of questions which the
state had to deal with apart from the
divisions which were mentioned here
already the problems of religion and
multi-ethnic etc with we may remember
that in the first foolish Republic in
the Commonwealth in the respond bika
there were in fact for foreign policy
dignitaries the transfers of this way
now couldn't
Bruce transfer over the crown with
retina problems the Hat months will be
dealt with the problems of the towers
its fourth so it was it is extremely
difficult to pass judgment not only over
the whole period a whole span of garbage
per foreign policy but without taking
into account the extreme complexity of
this is one of the questions which occur
to me another one was and I've already
said that Louis Eisenman the French he
started saying that it has been at
misfortune for Poland to be reborn as a
state which was too small to be a power
and to dodge to be satisfied with the
status of a sublight I think that this
is a very apt is a brief description of
the situation of the interwar period and
obviously it added to the complexity of
dealing with the issues the German
Russian of the German Soviet issue
protoje is he may be right in saying
that Poland has never had as favorable
strategic position I wouldn't quite
agree with that I think in the 16th
century this will be strategic position
wasn't so bad but and that cooperation
among Central European states is not a
novelty of the 20th century but the
apollonians practice it fairly effective
16 for a short time we'll see how the
shag rug developed the when I think of
the present day problems of programs of
being between I do not mean they are two
different options a neat option or a
American option or a European option I
simply mean that fall and it has to
engage once again in a certain balancing
act which is difficult at times and
which at times is not i would say played
at the best possible way my here i
disagree with regine ski that about the
public decision to support the united
states of iraq and i think that it would
have been much wiser to play a very
cautious roll sitting on the fence not
trying not to antagonize german it is
was one of the reasons where the german
police relations have curated and not
obviously uncolonized the united states
so this is this is the question at times
of moderation and of the feeling that
which was mentioned by the french
historian that the poles there are not
quite sure what category of states they
belong to there is the nostalgia about
being a greater power than or an actual
yes you must have noticed
that when one speaks of the new state so
forward joining it's always the tallest
stress that problems the biggest of
states there is this it may not be
parochialism I don't want to play with
words but there is a certain tendency
which I would call nostalgic tendency
historic tendency of trying to assert
odds position and at the same time being
extremely sensitive to criticism here I
would agree with Brzezinski and I would
like to draw your attention to a series
of a very interest in articles which
appeared in the last issue of the god of
Shakti by German than by poles dealing
with the german-polish syndrome and
trying to analyze the reasons work for
the reason generation and expressing
hopes for some kind of very slow change
with the feeling that a drastic change
for the better is not very likely in the
same way and I'd like to draw your
attention to an issue of the crop of
Arcana of which dr. Novak is their
editor would you deals with Polish
Russian aspects and there is an article
of Professor am g fat its key he is very
often going against the current in which
he tries to say well let's not be
offended all the time by
what the Russian to do let's try to be a
little bit less sensitive in American
politics and the argument often is or an
accusation of roughness against the
politician that he has to thinnest skin
but I'm fraid there on occasion it would
help the polls to have a little thicker
skin this is this is another observation
I don't believe as I could be the same
way in which I said that in the interwar
period then the Polish position nowadays
is in hundred times better than it was
then we all realize that and no
territorial issue with lemonade
difficulties with Russia which are bound
I think to continue as long as the
age-long contest over the influence of
the border area you crying your Russia
is likely to continue in one form or
another I don't see this this
disappearing but I hope that it will be
handled with a certain amount of
moderation and not they desire to reply
anytime something appears
the Russian press or statement which is
offensive to reply giving tit for tat I
don't think this is very good Plan C and
these are my observations at this point
I'd I would like to turn to Akkad thank
you very much we were asked to comment
on possible continuations and even
actualities of some elements of Polish
foreign policy throughout centuries and
it seems to me that one element needs to
be treated as still valid the fact that
Poland is positioned in a very special
way opened to the east of Europe and it
was positioned this way through its
union with Vito Annja in your head to
various some of them really beneficial
some of them may be detrimental contacts
with Eastern properties and European
problems but still if we look now on the
map of the European Union we have to
admit one thing that makes polish
position really special and there is
nothing parochial in it the fact that
this is the only country of the EU that
has common border with all three
post-soviet Slovak Republic the only one
country lead to a near borders only with
yellow Russia and Russian Federation
Latvia only with yellow Russia and
Russia Estonia only with Russia and
Hungary and Slovakia border only have a
common border only with with Ukraine so
Poland is unique in this respect in all
the European Union and this makes her
responsible to some extent of course I
wouldn't say that Poland is solely
responsible for
Stan policy of the European Union but is
naturally or geopolitically if you will
pre determined to have some initiative
in this respect and there we have some
problems that reminds us some historical
problems to problems from our history
when Professor Hashim of it presented
this contrast I would say that this
contrast seemed to me really to shop
between old good days of professors
could be sure skis rule and what
happened afterwards I would say that
part of this contrast might be
contributed to a real belief that
history had ended at that time not only
in Poland but most of all in i would say
general mood political mood in the
european union project as well russia
didn't post i would say in New York New
Russia didn't pose a real threat to the
EU project at that time President
Yeltsin was occupied with his internal
fight for power and couldn't i would say
express and as even more so and force
any reham paralyzing projects on russian
neighbors afterwards it it changed
really dramatically especially in past
five years when russia reintegrated
herself to some extent around the model
that that unfortunately is based not on
stable and democratic because i would
agree perfectly with professor
resumable statement that for Poland the
best situation to the east east stable
and democratic Russia but from Russian
perspective it is not and that either or
either stable or democratic this is how
Putin present it presents the situation
to his own people and what we can
ascertain along sociological different
data we get we got from from Russian
Federation now most of the population
agrees with this either stable or
democratic and this makes a real problem
we cannot overcome this with simple
words that we like to have a stable and
democratic Russia it is not the way
Russia exists and we have to deal with
it we can hope for the change we can do
anything we we can imagine not to make
an obstacle to the change in this
favorable
i would say outcome towards this
favorable outcome in Russia but now we
have to deal with real situation which
is that Russia is not democratic and is
stable and at the same time this
stabilized Russia stabilized under
totally authoritarianism of President
Putin has its own political agenda that
is very much contrary not only to polish
agenda but to the European Union agenda
of exporting democracy towards the east
so we don't have one project the
European Union project in Eastern Europe
but we have two projects the European
Union project that was extolled in very
much to justified way by Professor
Hadassah mortgage but we have to take
into account that there is another
project Russian project of reham
periodization and here is the problem
how we could deal with it just not to
spoil this relatively good situation we
have now and to enhance stability in
Eastern Europe by changing i would say
Russian relations to Russian European
neighbors I mean to Ukraine and tubular
Russia there is on Russian agenda a
reunification on of yellow Russia and
and Russia so we have to to tackle with
this problem this was not invented by
Professor Brzezinski this is political
path that is going on on our eyes so
what we can do about this can we appeal
to the EU to Brussels where where our
appeals most of the time find death
errors due to this kind of appeals as
standing from polish Russo phobic i
would say position parochial Russa
phobic position or we can do something
on this I would say that it seems to me
that the idea presented here by
Professor Brzezinski seems to me very
appealing and the only i would say
realistic we have to find allies within
the European Union to make our voice on
Eastern European problems much more
stronger much more persuasive and free
of this accusation of Polish
parochialism what do I have in mind
Germany first of course i would agree
without germany it wouldn't be possible
but it is possible only now after the
most outspoken ambassador of Russian
interests has gone I mean Chancellor
shredder he realized really the most
extravagant Russian interest within the
EU so now the change for Angela Merkel
is really a great chance for Poland if
we miss this chance this will be a real
calamity of our foreign policy I would
agree then with every critical remark on
our contemporary government if it misses
this chance this is really very
important to start new phase of not only
reconciliation but of real collaboration
with Germany now in order to avoid what
became a reality also a real
collaboration between Russia and Germany
over our heads which was not co-equal to
Ribbentrop Molotov pack of course but
was detrimental to polish interest of
course too but Germany is not alone as
our i would say possible ally in this
respect of course all Scandinavian
countries are also very important in
this respect and we shouldn't
neglect bilateral i would say relations
believing that the EU is is I would say
the final the final answer for all our
political problems no we have to
strengthen our position within the EU or
through finding allies and alliances
within the EU so we can find them as
regards Eastern European questions in
Sweden that helps very much estonia and
latvia in of course finland the same way
denmark and one of the examples that
that can be used in this respect is
delicate but stable and consequent
pressure on Germany within the EU to
withdraw from this really detrimental
project of the pipeline down under the
Baltic Sea which really makes a great
source of stress not only for poles but
also for Estonians fins and other i
would say baltic people so we are not
alone in this respect we have to find
partners not to be alone in our eastern
policy this is something really
important and we have to renew what was
rightly stressed by mr. ambassador here
our regional policy in central europe to
reinvigorate our cooperation with czech
republic with slovakia with hungary and
other i would say post-communist
countries that would also take the same
risk with destabilization of our eastern
border and we have to persuade them
which wouldn't be I believe so
impossible that we shall
very similar position within the EU
being on its eastern so to speak out
skirts though Poland easy however it
sounds may be parallel or or naive
predator me to be the most outspoken I
would say ambassador of this Eastern
European problems within the EU and this
is part of our historical legacy and
part of our still valid geopolitical
position okay so I say yeah do not
export demo Cassie by force we had a
very experienced with sorry but no one
was saying this so I don't know you are
saying that you you would force down
Democrats it on Russia this was traded
your icing it was something like it back
there okay I I didn't say 11 don't for
everything yes
a lot
I
so I'm sorry I
Oh
certainly is
yes exactly I like to compare her
question on Iran special jerseys he said
that he once we know he doesn't doesn't
believe that it was proper for beyoncé's
to do this but he is all advantage told
to go along i gue surrounded by much
the case well I can also put a little
stronger test it was a 2 a 3 a half of
unprovoked aggression pokerap and that
we can copy is slowly waiting dr. david
and come realizes what most of the
others of servers of the steam paralyzed
at work was really focusing on united
states by the boys really large extent
photography
now is this war looks like goes into its
disastrous air United States going to
wake up and down with its hand man
Michael as yourself Jesus tangled roots
me and I my question analysis first of
all his own don't wake up its finger in
the night walk along the United take a
second what do you think why
controversial thought former but isn't
it president and also pensions from a
task to produce for halloween is dead
attention the real the box against the
party I think that both of us can answer
that very briefly or speculate on it I
can say as far as my home position is
concerned it will best expressed in a
letter sent to the building project lee
some time ago and quit right side that
the famous lines from bonds lynskey
gentility go for sheriff sandy
Przewalski's one how and i tried to draw
certain comparison between the polish
legalities lines stain helping
Napoleon
and to democratize thing so that my
position of that is completely clear and
i think that the policy of the american
government and dr. disease he was very
diplomatic today but less diplomatic in
an article which appeared in her opinion
if which he really let himself down
which his photo booth suicidal policies
now as for the reasons of the motivation
of the purdue government I'm not in a
position to say that because you might
want to judge just want to share with
you information you probably know that
the first public opinion were not the
wine supporting while supporting us
generally well against war in Iraq yeah
yeah yeah so that decide yeah yeah
excuse me but actually I would like to
correct it the Polish public opinion was
not overwhelmingly against as in Spain
or as in France or as in Germany that
was almost even fifty-fifty situation so
it is very risky to say that polish
public opinion was overwhelmingly
against ended Polish government and
polish president acted against you can
sorry yes but majority measured by polls
especially in Poland
is not a very i would say accurate
number usually so i would i would answer
only maybe it's likely a different way
to your question it seems to me though I
I can I am no spokesman especially
president Kwasniewski still I think I
presume that he intended to get
something for it and he got nothing
that's the problem that's the problem
redesign and I would compare the
situation maybe not to polish regulate
business guy in Spain but there is much
closer comparison to polish legia not
business guy in Haiti yes
let me start with rework I think what we
are doing right now this is what can be
described easily put this situation in
Iraq out of the context which was two
years ago and let me just rewrite there
was a bit about the National Committee
about the threat assessment
22 good heart was was real but the
pressurization
no situation where the United States
I and our understanding of the Alliance
is that this is no two-way street we
want to be if you want to yeah if we
want to account of the United States as
an error we have the obligation
I propose we take last question several
statements
not too much to do
way and not to be offended if Russian
officials the president offense other
and this in other word the Russian
aspect has not been clarified so I
developed stability and democracy
everyone mr. Putin when much further he
said and we Russia will be gay or tone
and in and in aligned with this approach
he said also several times Russia will
be governed centralized because it was
governed like that you in sighs period
in the Soviet people and
not young so mr. proteins view has
another European is also a little
research for several European
perceptions one European perceptions is
the Eurasian perception which should be
inspected as innocuous Russia blueprint
a sample it is for historians themselves
of some interest you know then basically
that this conception Eurasian conception
was invented by very respectable not
happiness in emigration implant the yes
to be scoring an other significant their
Russian think has invented the
conception of Eurasian good UHA which is
too deadly official of you of the
Russian government so her sure has its
own air engine
sections of work where how W is usually
Europe it had into all analyses
successful but in a great day Antarctica
France Germany Russia that this will be
a better Europeans and it has a number
of others and russia russian government
under President Putin has rudely
interfere in the number of democratic
elections you came comes to mind we
remember how Russian booty our personal
booty walk into the youth in several
times and quantity would be next
presentation let's see we say all this
is in sir I mean we nasty things about
President Bush's behavior how are you in
he went to Mexico and told the Mexicans
home to Iraq for president not only
level conservatives will be from this
kid ate it is made so I'm English
gallatin father for tuition balance
Stanford resolute approach Tasha was not
rubbing the Russians thank you something
I yet another second last question yep I
just wanted to very briefly repeat
something which professor chin shawa
actually said in a completely different
context and earlier in the day and that
is the importance of energy supplies
none of the two major conflicts that we
have been talking about disagreeing
about the Iraq war but the more German
Russian rapprochement over gas
inconceivable if the major powers of the
Western world were energy independent
therefore is a most non polish and non
parochial and generally about the
European and the United States to aim
for energy independence were that to be
solved many of these other things with
appear to be second-rate and yeah that
was no no are you in Bosnia yeah
probably takes so long between to be
four things on conf ado I just want to
bring for attention I don't think that
came out one is specific relation with
the Vatican in Rome
for a long period of full information at
the country and because of unique
situation and on all the second and
reemergence darkest was a long
continuity issue the second is Poland
special relationship with dirty the only
society was look to Turkey at the point
of liberation and took degree oriental
eyes in Turkish model and today I
understand society's acceptance of
Turkey and I think those are the two
issues with vulnerability work John
close the fish delighted to be here and
for those of you who have been here
since nine o'clock in the morning my
thanks you have more sits flush than I
do for those of you who came later today
thank you for coming this event was made
possible by a number of organizations
who interact occasionally in different
areas of course the pilsudski Institute
the separate Polonia foundation and the
Polish Senate which sent money across
the Atlantic to help us the Polish
Studies program which is funded by the
Polish Slovak federal credit union the
kosciuszko foundation our great source
of support and right now I can't imagine
how many more institutions but I can
tell you that this is not the last time
we will be doing a meeting like this I
think it will be difficult to top this
in the sense that we had a number of
very good specialists in a keynoter who
really I think gave people some ideas to
bounce their ideas off the next
conference that we will be doing in the
spring will probably have to do with
Visser grout and will not have an
exclusively polish focus but we'll have
a Ukrainian focus in which Poland will
play of course a very great role now
none of this would have been possible
without the exacting and and really
tough work of dr. evona drum corps yahoo
sitting in the back the director of the
pistol
and my colleague my Lithuanian colleague
Kevin Hallahan who still made the
arrangements even though he's still
angry about General Zod gulfs keep
taking Vilnius in 1920 and I think he'll
forgive us if we won't mention it to
them any time in the near future I now
invite one and all to a reception here
in the lobby let's go have a little
schnapps and inache thank you